season 18 of the voice congratulations
Kelly I mean you have won this show
three times now so yeah you know what it
takes so how would you assess the
strength of your team this time around
um you know each season is different and
I will I say this every time and I'm not
just saying it to be like the pageant
girl but like really it just depends on
who you get on your team who picks you
because you usually from the beginning
like I knew Jake was gonna be in the
finale it's like I knew it from the
beginning and and you know with Bryn and
Chevelle I just super people that I
either kind of stick out to you so it
does you know we all had a feeling Malin
would have won mm-hmm that was on John's
team so it kind of just depends who
picture you get it's the luck of the
draw
sometimes but it's a lot of hard work
though as far as like really instilling
confidence it's not really they all have
voices it's instilling that confidence
and instilling that just assurance that
reassurance of how they feel on stage by
themselves but and you have some added
strength this season some girl power
here with you I love it why do I um well
first of all I'm not a joke I literally
sing her songs all the time like I'm
literally my husband's probably like
shut up in the shower like that like I
love your new song like what the like
walk away you know how that's the best
line of 2020 as far as I'm concerned
like it's so great it's like the John
Kia Zach with the thing with like the
jerk you hate at their house it's like
the best line but she's just really good
writer singer dancer like all-around
entertainer and like there aren't only a
few of you like inna and I'm saying that
do all of that
like the jailors the beyonce is like are
there only a few of you that really nail
all of that so I thought it would be
really cool it is called the voice but
there are people like Hello Sunday
lassies they love dancing like you know
our Kennedy homes on jennifer has season
or they're dancers this season too so
it's nice to have people that that are
mentors like duaa that have like kind of
an ear into all of that you know they
have their hand in all of that so duo
what do you hope to bring to team Kelly
well I'm just I wanted to have been
chosen and you know watching Kelly
basically for the five seasons that
she's been here she's won three times I
feel like that's that's already I don't
think she needed my help to be never
I'm so you know I'm so grateful to get
to learn a whole new kind of a whole new
dimension really this is something that
I haven't really done before and it's
really exciting to see you know young
artists and people who are just starting
their dream and gets so excited and so
passionate they're like sponges
everything that Kelly tells and they
take they they take all those notes and
they just want to learn and they just
want to grow and it's for me it's so
exciting to be a part of that process
and also to learn from Kelly and to see
the kind of advice that she gives
because it's not just even even for me
like everything that Kelly is saying
like I'm taking that on board myself and
I'm like that's really good advice
actually I got to actually sit in the
same way I think it's really good
because I feel like as artists you need
to be constantly learning and from every
experience that you get thrown into
especially new experiences all I want to
do is learn from this process myself and
try and be as helpful as I can to new
artists and try and give my two cents I
know that they're only here for you but
I'm just hired literally to like it was
hilarious because two of them like I
announced because they're singing her
song on my team and two of them I was
like well so I just figured we'd bring
her in to like and it was kind of
holding outs to being on my mentor for
this season and they were freaking out
like here it was really cool to have
artists like her that are really
relevant in time for you know music
right now and this time and really
nailing it and like her caring about
these people that have the same dream
it means the world because I've been
those people and I know that so it's
just a really cool thing to have someone
like her especially you know not just to
sing or not she saying it's your bit of
ride or all the things it's really cool
and I love the female empowerment
between you yeah well I love females so
before Sister Wives
well switching gears we do have a new
coach this season mr. Nick Jonas yeah
what would you say has been his strategy
so far trying to get people on his team
well here's the thing about Nick that
maybe everybody doesn't know is you it's
easy to go in on John
Blake and even Gwen a little bit keno
cuz like I don't know that there's just
as easy to go in on there it's hard to
go in on Nick and that's his strength
cuz he's so nice it's like the nicest
guy ever that you feel like a jerk but
you just even make a joke and I'm like
wait he's so nice I can't say that but
like you can't mess with him as much
that's been the but I think that's his
trick he's like so nice thing he's like
we everybody can't kind of go near him
and he's been like I mean he he and I
thought the most and battles or were
they in the blinds yeah he and I were
the ones that would we kind of knew that
- we'd never been ring between each ooh
like there's no competitive and sorry
just over people not okay no and he's um
he's super nice at one point I was like
quit being nice no is he is fenomena
utilizing his brothers as an advantage
cuz i may or may not have seen some
names written on tape here of Kevin and
Joe oh yeah they might probably work
they come in and out to do stuff and
also Joe has done the voice before right
and the UK or its Australia or cut
remember yeah okay overseas yeah
overseas and so um he had done it before
so yeah I think he talked to his brother
a bit but I mean I think Nick being a
child star really like from the
beginning it's kind of nice to have
someone we've never had anyone that
young on this show you know be a coach
so it's kind of cool because you
wouldn't think someone his age would
have that much experience but he has
since he was a little kid so but his
thing his strength is that he's like the
nicest individual in the world so you
think it's hard to like battle him
because you're like I'm gonna look like
a turd right do it what would you do you
have any words for Nick now that you've
seen the strength of Kelly's team and
your team do you know Nick if y'all run
into each other um I don't I don't
really know him okay
like the human well I'm gonna say given
that he's so nice
okay is watch out no also late to what
about his strategy because you have feed
him multiple times with the country
artist is he trying to make sure that
that does not happen again no I think
that I mean at this point Blake's been
doing it 18 seasons and I mean we
definitely you know any times there's a
there's a country artist we both turn
but I don't think he out of the key it's
all for fun like we both definitely went
away we're competitive but at the same
time we both have similar connections
and that world like and we both really
want the best for the artists after the
show and he really has like I hate
saying this but whatever but he really
has taught me how to be a good coach in
the sense of like afterwards like I saw
him from the first season I saw him
really working for these artists like
paying for like apartments like paying
for so that they can come out here and
record and do things like he really does
put his money where his mouth is when it
comes to his artists and and I really
learned from that because my husband you
know obviously made it just him so I got
to see all of that and that's the only
compliment I'm giving him lastly really
quick now that it's 20 20 year Vegas
residency is right yeah April how are
you balancing the voice your talk show
the residency and your family man I'm
gonna get some tips from duaa for my
Vegas residency because I feel like I've
seen a lot of shows and I my show is not
a normal one for Vegas so I'm kind of
excited to try some new stuff that I
haven't done but like I don't know we I
don't really get like usually - really
about the singing and the songs and and
I don't know I'm mixed I'm excited at
the opportunity of like you'll get this
like you can only do so much on tour
because you have to travel with it yeah
so with Vegas it's kind of cool because
I'm like well I want an orchestra and
you can happen to work faster because
you're in Vegas what you want you
so you can like ask for things and you
kind of get it but I'm literally this is
gonna be the biggest show I've ever done
just because it's Vegas and you can and
you're in one place and I'm not able to
tour because of all the jobs so if and
kids so yeah it was a really good step
for me but I need to learn some from
this one because I've seen all her
performances on award shows I'm like I
wanna see make is gonna be like waxing
we be afraid blender in the front no if
she ups to my show I'm totally pulling
her on stage
[Music]